most of the people who watch this
podcast will know and in fact i believe
andy was my first
guest back in the the early days of dark
horse
andy is a local independent journalist
who has been
absolutely dogged about revealing what
is taking place
on the streets of portland when the
mainstream news was absolutely
pretending that it wasn't happening so
throughout
the uh the rioting um andy was there and
he was one of the few places you could
go to figure out
what was occurring in the streets of
portland um
he's got a he's got a bias he's got a
slant he's
unapologetically conservative and he
sees
um nothing to recommend what antifa are
doing and it's unlikely if they started
to do anything
started doing things that were
recommendable that he would be the first
to notice
but you know what his bias is and he
doesn't he doesn't hide it
well
there's there's more to say here i think
you know
um i would say uh douglas murray
has a bias but he navigates it in a way
that um never troubles me
or at least not that i've seen andy
is not the same there's some places
where andy has done some things that
make me
recoil a bit on the other hand i would
point out
that andy is in a very vulnerable
position
he's on the ground here in portland
where he is
absolutely loathed by his subject right
as he is
looking at the violence on the streets
of portland they are out to get him
his his murder is being called for in
graffiti around downtown
it's really a very difficult situation
at the same time
he is um bootstrapping a method of
feeding himself in other words there's
an there is no niche for the independent
journalist on the ground
uh reporting on a mob that hates him and
wants him dead
um but he's doing it and so uh
while on the one hand i think it is
important
you know to figure out how to keep
one's biases out of one's reporting and
i i want andy
to do that i also recognize that he has
been able to do what nobody else is able
to do which is to report that this story
on the ground consistently in spite of
tremendous danger
to him and his family and so
anyway i'm i'm rooting for for him to
find a model that allows him
uh to you know we all have our biases
but
if you're a reporter uh you got to keep
them out of your reporting
nonetheless andy has been reporting this
story he has a book
coming out i believe the title is
unmasked unmasked inside antifa's
radical plan to destroy democracy
so which sounds like absolute hyperbole
until you talk to some antifa folks and
you discover that actually
they'll tell you that uh they're more or
less you mean they
burn flags repeatedly in front of the
courthouse here and all that and on
inauguration day um
they had an another protest saying um
i think you know [ __ ] biden um yeah
yeah they're no more interested in peace
now than they were during the trump era
right and the
alignment uh you know people should go
back to my discussion
uh with jeremy lee quinn to get the you
know there is an ancestral relationship
between antifa and anti-racism which i
didn't know
but nonetheless the confluence of blm
and antifa is more or less accidental
um and they have now more or less parted
company in portland for
you know reasons that are easily
understood but
in any case um uh so andy has the book
coming out
uh in like april i think something oh
february i don't know
um and wouldn't you know it antifa oh
no let's go back to the the inauguration
day rights the inauguration day
riots here in portland were actually an
attack on the democratic party
headquarters locally
um you know not symbolic they broke
windows
clearly the same same violence we see
from them routinely
and there were banners in front uh
that said we are ungovernable right they
are declaring
the equivalent of war on the structures
that allow us to function as a society
they are anarchist even though they
uh claim when we say things like that
that we don't know what we're talking
about but no by the
deaf and by the self-definition of
anarchists they meet it right and just
and declaring yourself ungovernable
uh makes the subtitle here a radical
plan to destroy democracy
makes sense yep makes sense um so in any
case
uh very important that a guy like andy
with first-hand knowledge of this
has a book coming out not at all
surprising that the
subjects of his book who are not
flatteringly portrayed i don't know how
you would flatteringly portray them but
right you know but he makes no attempt
he makes no attempt to
routinely uh reveals what they're up to
how violent it is and it
destroys their narrative that they are
responding to federal fascism or
whatever
um but they don't want that book sold at
powell's books in downtown portland
shocking i'm terribly surprised that
they are against the publication
and sale of this book right what is
shocking
is that powell's has responded to this
with something other than a vigorous
dispense uh defense of free speech
yeah so um they have a long
thing online pals does in response um
but the first paragraph and you can
you can show my screen if you want zach
powell's commitment to free speech
dear pals community at pals a lot of our
inventory is hand selected and hand
promoted
and a lot of our inventory is not
unmasked by andy now came to us via one
of our long-term and respected
publishers
hatchet book group we list the majority
of their catalog on pals.com
automatically as do many other
independent and larger retailers
we have a similar arrangement with other
publishers since i'll just go one more
um
one more paragraph here since sunday
palace has received hundreds of emails
calls and social media comments calling
for us to remove unmasked from pals.com
due to protests outside our burnside
location that's an auxiliary location
we have chosen to close our store
including curbside pickup to keep our
employees and customers safe
we are monitoring the situation daily
and we will reopen when it is safe to do
so
our other locations on website remain
open so it goes
it goes on and it's all this very
very backpedalling soft like mealy mouth
kind of defensive free speech
and the first day i went down to pals
the main one
downtown pearl district they were closed
and i was shocked i i was i was
interested
interested to see what it was going to
look like there and
presumably because it was closed there
was nothing going on at all except i was
standing there reading this sign on
their door
um when a couple of other women came up
behind me
and murmured oh i wanted to go in i wish
it were open
it's seeming not to know why they were
close because there's nothing
there was nothing on the sign outside
the door on the door that explained
we're closed because a mob came and
tried to censor us
like try right like this this was this
is about
one of the world's i think biggest
independent booksellers
responding to cries to not sell a book
right and their defense is
we didn't pick it it's in the catalog we
sell lots of things from catalogs
we're never going to have hard copies in
the store don't worry about that right
like people can still order it online
from us if they if they need to
we wouldn't but if they need to right
but certainly you don't want it you know
you can't buy it in the store
and we will reopen when it's safe
effectively giving antifa control
over when powell's is open and when not
well they were open then
a few days ago um and nothing nothing
was happening
right but my point is to even say that
yes
it reveals the failure of the full stack
here because what's really going on
you know yes powell should make a
full-throated defense of free speech and
it should say
you know books are about ideas we do not
vet them in advance uh you are more than
welcome to purchase a copy of the book
disagree with it in whatever way
um you wish and you know you have
numerous freedoms that would allow you
to write a vigorous response which we
would also carry blah blah blah blah
blah
right they could do a lot of things
what's really happened here is
the mayor who said
one heartening thing about enforcing the
law after the election and then
basically things have gone back to the
way they were beforehand with the
kid gloves and and all
but because we are not enforcing the law
and because
a violent group is allowed to attack a
bookstore so that it does not carry
a book by a journalist who is exposing
that very
group right this is just this is the
collapse of civil society this
is not only you don't necessarily have
the right to speak but um
you are subject to effective
violent editing by exactly those
on whom you report right so um
this is the failure of freedom of the
press it is the failure
of our governance structure yes powell's
is a private entity
but our city government is not and it
has obligations to
uh to protect uh andy and it has
obligations to protect
and if powell's and if it can't do it
here right if the city government
do it for powell's than portland is
doomed right like powell's
is extremely popular with portlanders
they are
rightly proud of powell's this amazing
destination for tourists when there were
tourists
yeah it is it is one of the shining
examples of a
a a brilliant non-chain bookstore
and therefore if mayor wheeler
were to have the police enforce the law
and protect powers this is the thing
that is most likely to wake people up
to where we have where we where we find
ourselves
and it's not happening so it's not
happening it's not this
what if not this what exactly and i
guess the the
one other thing this made me think about
was the nature of episodic behavior
and you know we spoke a lot during the
summer and the early fall when the
protests were still happening
every night in portland and they
reliably as the sunset became riots and
yet um some i don't know how many of
them were simply confused and
how many of them were intentionally
being deceptive but some journalists
would say well
here i am at noon in some random square
and i don't see any protests so i guess
this is a lie i don't see any riots
and you know the idea that something has
to be happening at all times everywhere
in order to be happening at some time
somewhere is obviously a ridiculous
proposition
and if you say it that way it's revealed
but somehow most people can't keep that
very simple fact in their head for very
long
so you know were were those protests
mostly peaceful
well actually in portland every single
night they became they went from
peaceful to not peaceful every single
night like
clockwork it was actually more like sun
work because as the
time of the sunset changes so did the
time of the onset of the riots
it was regular it was predictable and
all you had to do
was be in the quote unquote right place
at the quote unquote right time
to see what was going on and if you
didn't go there
at that time in those places then you
wouldn't see and of course there were
actually
three or four or five regular locations
that the that the violence was happening
um mostly peaceful well
you know by some metrics i guess if you
want to do the math that way but that's
not journalism is it
and you know this maybe this is totally
irrelevant but
i was reminded actually of hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy
of douglas adams fabulous five book
trilogy
with regard to the uh the double entry
that earth gets on the hitchhiker's
guide to the galaxy so if if memory
serves it's been a while
um ford prefect who's actually an alien
um but has picked the um he thinks
unassuming name ford prefect with which
to live
on earth for it turns out decades
because he misses his
he misses his ride he's missed his ride
right so he's stuck there and he
befriends arthur dent
and um the two of them managed to hit
your ride on a vogon spaceship i think
you know within minutes of ruth's
destruction
um and the hitchhiker's guide to the
galaxy is then both the book
that ford prefect is writing for um but
also
encyclopedic it's an encyclopedic
reflection of all of you know if if
you're hitchhiking around the galaxy
where might you go and
what might you do in order to find drink
food and yes might you suck on your
towel to get nutrients all of this
um when he was sent to earth to
update the entry the entry for earth
read
harmless and through dint of
decades of work um he managed to double
the length of the entry
to mostly harmless and i think
mostly harmless accurately describes
earth about as well
as mostly peaceful describes the
protests and riots
that have been happening in the u.s
since the end of may yes i
i agree with you now that you say it
douglas adams seems to have anticipated
this foolish moment
yeah sorry he's not here to see oh i am
uh i am too